the cdc now says the more contagious and
potentially more deadly strain of the
virus
first discovered in the u.s in the uk
rather is now the dominant variant here
in the u.s
and while we know the pandemic has taken
a terrible terrible toll on people's
physical health
new research shows how it's affecting
people's mental well-being
a uk study looking mostly at american
patients
finds that one in three coveted
survivors suffers
neurological or mental disorders within
six months of infection wow and among
patients treated in the icu
seven percent suffered a stroke and
nearly two percent were diagnosed with
dementia
researchers also found 17 percent of
patients developed anxiety and 14
experience mood disorders one covert
survivor told ian lee about his
life-altering experiences discovered
things you know it's allowed me to see
things that i otherwise wouldn't have
seen
ivan agarton has his dream job traveling
the world as an adventure photographer
there wasn't much that scared this
former marine
but that was before he caught covid last
fall and that really really worried me
because i have three small children and
my wife of course and i didn't want them
to get sick
weeks later the 50 year old from seattle
thought he recovered
that's when his world changed it
instantly like a light switch
i felt this intense paranoia hit me i
couldn't
escape it it kept every single person
that i saw would trigger
this this intense fear what was more
terrifying
he recognized the mental illness as it
was happening
my rational mind was still intact i
thought this is absolutely crazy what's
happening this isn't real this this
can't be real
doctors eventually linked his condition
to covet
and he's not alone essentially a third
of the patients in our 230 000 patients
after covered
had one or more psychiatric or diagnosis
dr paul harrison's team at oxford
university found
covet patients were treated more often
for a range of disorders from
common ones like anxiety and depression
to rare conditions like dementia and in
ivan's case
psychosis it was absolutely the most
terrifying thing i've ever experienced
in my life
what would you say then is the turning
point two weeks ago when i started
feeling
really good after i had my vaccination
ivan's back at work but still worries
how long is this going to stay with me
he hopes by sharing his story others
will also find the courage
to ask for help for cbs this morning ian
lee
in london and psychiatrist dr
sue varma joins us now sue good morning
this is uh
this was such a disturbing study uh when
i initially read the story
what's the biggest impact covet is
having on mental health
we're seeing that people 13 of people
who have never had psychiatric illnesses
before
neurological problems before are getting
this for the first time
and we're seeing anxiety being the most
common followed by depression followed
by insomnia
substance abuse and in very rare cases
even psychosis
who's at risk the people that are most
at risk are the ones who were the
sickest the hospitalized patients the
ones
who were in the icu those are the ones
who are more at risk for the more
serious conditions that we talked about
the strokes and the dementia and the
delirium which is a waxing and waning of
consciousness
but the scariest part are people who
didn't even have
either coveted symptoms or very mild
coveted symptoms that resolved
or prior psychiatric known illnesses
they too are at risk for the anxiety and
the depression and you know it's hard to
be able to tease apart is it because of
the hospitalization and just the fear
and the economic impact and all the
layers
of the pandemic or was there something
also medical going on and that's what
this
study picked up that there was something
medical going on in the brain right
so i mean we're talking about people who
have never experienced symptoms like
this before
in many cases precisely and that is so
scary especially when you're hearing
voices or the voices are telling you to
harm yourself or harm other people or
that other people are out to get you
so um these type of symptoms are they
ever linked to other kinds of viral
infections
you know they are but you know not to
the manifestation not to the extent that
it is when
they compared in this study to uh covet
the flu or code it to uh
other control groups or other
respiratory symptoms you saw that uh the
covet was twice as likely to produce
these neuropsychiatric
problems as compared to the flu so this
is something really unique
and the fact that people could have mild
coveted symptoms mild respiratory
symptoms and yet
major mental health and major
neuropsychiatric problems i i noted that
ivan said
in in the story that that he started
feeling better after he got the
vaccination
what what should people do in in this
case
yeah so the first thing is never
underestimate or minimize your uh
mental health concerns because they very
much may be linked to the inflammation
that cobot caused in the body you know i
think of covid really as a
multi-organ system illnesses many
doctors understand this because of the
blood vessels that are injured
we have inflammation neurotoxins in the
brain um
and we need to be able to talk to both
the primary care doctors sometimes
they're
long-term care centers dedicated to
covet and also speak to a behavioral
health specialist and finally talk to
your family about developing a care plan
a lot of people are having brain fog
memory problems
it's affecting their people's ability to
function at home and functioning the
family so really be able to have a
comprehensive plan with the primary care
doctor your family and
a behavioral health specialist as we saw
for many people these things are
lingering dr
sue varma thank you so much